if you come to this location the week of
Thanksgiving it will blow your mind I
mean thousands and thousands of pies I
don't think they sleep they just bake
Thanksgiving is our busiest time of the
year and we are making about 12 to
15,000 pies that week to know that we
are putting so many pies out of this one
small place in Brooklyn and then it's
going to go into kitchens or dining room
tables all over the city it's really an
amazing
feeling my name is Petra parades and I
am the owner of P's Pie Company to me a
great Pie has a really tender and
flavorful crust and the filling is
really nice and balanced um so I I don't
want it to just be sweet if it's a fruit
pie I want it to be sweet and a little
tart just like you know biting into a
nice piece of
fruit I as a kid I didn't always know
what my friends parents did they they
worked in offices my parents had a Pie
Bakery and they made pies so it was very
straightforward and simple and wherever
we went we brought pies so um it's
always been such a big deal to us even
when we went to uh other restaurants we
would buy pies to
try Thanksgiving was always a really
bustling and busy time I have three
siblings we would stay home from school
cuz my parents were simply too busy to
take us to school and uh we would work
alongside our parents we were wrapping
pies we were getting pies for orders uh
greeting customers and and going back to
retrieve their pies and for us it felt
like a really fun and important thing to
do we were always super exhausted so we
would go to Thanksgiving dinner at my
aunt and uncle's house but for us just
sort of coing down uh into a few pie
selections for Thanksgiving dinner is
super tricky so we would tend to bring
usually around like 20
pies we're heading over to the uh the
burrow Hall Green Market which is where
we're going to pick up some
pumpkins one thing that a lot of people
don't know is that when they buy a can
of pumpkin at the store they are
typically made with neck pumpkins which
sort of look like a an elongated
butternut squash it's not the little
round orange pumpkins typically that you
identify as a pumpkin they are
essentially the same botanically with
minor differences for me a butternut
squash or a blend of butternuts and
Cabas those are the nicest produce to
use to make a pumpkin
[Music]
pie
a lot of my recipes come from my dad's
recipes as a starting point and then I
and then I Chang them and but there are
some pies that I encountered um just
sort of by chance um when we first
started our Bakery my husband told me
about the New York Public Libraries menu
project where they um where they upload
old restaurant menus from New York City
and and Beyond one really interesting
pie that I kept seeing on these menus
was Nestle Road pie it used to be a New
York classic uh pie offering that sort
of went extinct and that made me want to
um make my own version of
it pumpkin pie is the sort of print
essential Thanksgiving pie I I think
it's because it's part of that mythology
of our our apocryphal first Thanksgiving
it's a perfect symbol of sharing because
it is one dish that we that we cut up
and we distribute among the table um and
that sort of circle the the shape of a
pie itself sort of represents wholeness
and I think there's a there's a sort of
cultural significance of it being a
combination of squash or pumpkins um
that are native to the Americas being
blended with European culinary
Traditions I've read a lot about pumpkin
pies one of the original Proto uh
pumpkin pies may have been a pumpkin
that has been hollowed out and with a
sweet custard you know just a you know
sugar eggs and cream baked inside of it
way back in history pie crust was often
a a baking vessel I'm talking you know
the medieval AG es perhaps um it would
be a sort of almost more like a pot that
has been made out of flour and water you
could eat it if you had to but you would
more likely eat the contents out of it
and then use it again and um these days
luckily we don't have to resort to that
and we can make a nice tender buttery
crust that that we actually want to
[Music]
eat
woohoo no I haven't had a pumpkin pie
before I'm excited I've never had a
pumpkin pie before nor have I ever
wanted to have a pumpkin pie just does
not appeal to me I've been to a few
thanksgivings uh but I normally ate so
much at the beginning that there wasn't
much room left at the end yeah I like
pumpkin eat pumpkin probably mostly
around Halloween sometimes it's in
certain foods I eat they have like a
pumpkin that you put in so I'm the guy
to eat some pumpkin pie you know what I
am I haven't actually tried pumpkin pie
before um this is this is new Halloween
is about as close as I get to even seen
a pumpkin all year if I had to guess
what's in a pumpkin pie obviously the
first thing would be pumpkin but I'm not
too sure what else would be in a pie I'm
assuming uh looking at the base like
well obviously bread uh I think there's
pumpkin in it my first guess is going to
be some sort of pumpkin or gourd squash
sugar hoping butter I'm going to assum
Pumpkin um and
then cinnamon pumpkin impatience or
confume something that's got that in
there I'd be
happy okay how big how big a bite are we
talking go for the end
I might go crust end cuz I want like a
50/50 I want like some you know oh it's
so so moist and Squishy oh God that was
easy it's a good
pie it's a good
pie you ain't getting it back I'm going
to eat it the pumpkin's not that strong
sweet but not too sweet pastry is nice
and firm I like a cold tart I'm I'm
going to have another
bite yeah it's giving it's giving
cheesecake to test it again let me see
what the taste in
it that's incredibly tasty it reminds me
of carrot cake it tastes amazing I don't
even like
pumpkin wow that's incredible I'm
feeling like a American baldheaded Eagle
right now
that's how much I'm loving this pie
genuinely very tasty peties
[Music]
pies